avec lui on s'est rencontré pour la
première fois dans dans mon bureau vous
avez déjà de retard j'avais deux heures
de retard et c'était un test pour savoir
s'il était assez motivé pour me voir et
effectivement il m'a attendu et je me
suis dit ce gars là ce gars-là il a la
foi
je peux dire ce que je pensais de toi
parce que j'arrive dans le bureau on
avait rendez-vous à 16h30 je suis arrivé
à 18h30 et donc j'arrive et je le vois
et là juste ce qu'on appelle
un cdfp un coup de foudre professionnel
j'ai dit ce mec là
il a le talent lui
on a parlé cinq minutes je lui ai dit
c'est bon combien tu veux il m'a marqué
sur une enveloppe comment il voulait
elle dit c'est bon tu peux partir
pour moi je le redis je n'ai pas peur de
le dire
c'est un des plus grands talents de la
télévision française
pour moi il fait partie même je le dis
bien en terme de talon je pense vraiment